- ברוכים השבים ל"הבנת
מידע קוונטי וחישוב".
שמי John Watrous ואני
המנהל הטכני של IBM Quantum Education.
זהו השיעור השישי בסדרה והוא השיעור השני
ביחידה השנייה של הסדרה, שעוסקת באלגוריתמים קוונטיים.
בשיעור הקודם, דיברנו על מודל
השאילתות של חישוב, וראינו שבמודל הזה, אלגוריתמים קוונטיים יכולים
לספק יתרון מרשים
על פני אלגוריתמים קלאסיים, כולל יתרון אקספוננציאלי במקרה של הבעיה של Simon.
למרבה הצער, למודל
השאילתות אין באמת רלוונטיות
ישירה או מיידית למעשה.
המושג של קופסה שחורה הוא הפשטה
מאוד שימושית כפי שמתברר, אבל יש לנו קצת עבודה לעשות
אם אנחנו רוצים ליישם
את התובנות שצברנו
ממודל השאילתות להגדרה חישובית יותר סטנדרטית שבה קלטים ניתנים כמחרוזות של ביטים
ולא כאורקלים או קופסאות שחורות.
המטרה העיקרית של השיעור הזה היא לבסס תשתית
שממנה נוכל לעשות את זה.
הנה סקירה של השיעור. בחלק הגדול של השיעור, אנחנו הולכים להתמקד
בעלות חישובית,
או במילים אחרות, כמה קשות משימות
חישוביות שונות ואיך אנחנו יכולים למדוד את הקושי הזה.
באופן גס, זה מתורגם לכמה זמן אנחנו צריכים לחכות
עד שחישובים יסתיימו ובסופו של דבר אילו
בעיות חישוביות
אנחנו יכולים לפתור ואילו
מעבר להישג ידינו.
אנחנו הולכים להתחיל עם
כמה דוגמאות. פירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים וחישוב מחלקים משותפים
גדולים ביותר או GCD בקיצור.
אלה דוגמאות טובות מאוד להמחשת
העקרונות הבסיסיים, ושתיהן גם
רלוונטיות מאוד לאלגוריתם של Shor, שנדון בו בשיעור הבא,
אז למעשה
נקבל תועלת כפולה מהדוגמאות האלה.
אחר כך נדון במושג של עלויות חישוביות באופן כללי יותר ואיך אנחנו יכולים למדוד אותן.
יש הרבה דרכים שונות
שאפשר לעשות את זה, אבל נתמקד באופן צר
למדי באיך אפשר לעשות את זה עם מודלים של circuit של חישוב,
ספציפית circuit בוליאניים
ו-circuit קוונטיים.
המיקוד כאן יהיה על אלגוריתמים בניגוד לחומרת
מחשב, למשל, ונהיה יותר מעוניינים
באיך שהעלויות של
הרצת אלגוריתם מתרחבות ככל שמופעי הבעיה הספציפיים שהוא רץ עליהם גדלים במידה ולא
בכמה שניות,
דקות, או שעות שחישוב
מסוים דורש.
הרעיון שמניע את נקודת המבט הזו הוא שלאלגוריתמים יש
חשיבות יסודית.
עד היום, אנחנו
עדיין מריצים אלגוריתמים שפותחו
לפני הרבה מאוד זמן ובאופן טבעי מאוד, הם ייפרסו
על מופעי בעיה גדולים
יותר ויותר באמצעות חומרה מהירה ואמינה יותר ככל שהטכנולוגיה מתפתחת.
והאופן שבו הם מתרחבים אומר לנו הרבה
על כמה הם שימושיים וכמה הם ימשיכו להיות שימושיים.
בחלק האחרון של השיעור, נפנה למשימה קריטית, שהיא הרצת חישובים קלאסיים
על מחשבים קוונטיים. הסיבה שזה חשוב היא לא כי אנחנו מקווים להחליף מחשבים קלאסיים
במחשבים קוונטיים,
מה שנראה מאוד לא סביר שיקרה בקרוב אם בכלל, אלא כי זה פותח
הרבה אפשרויות מעניינות
לאלגוריתמים קוונטיים.
ספציפית, ברגע שאנחנו יודעים איך להריץ חישובים קלאסיים
על מחשבים קוונטיים, הם הופכים לזמינים לאלגוריתמים
קוונטיים כתתי-שגרות
כך שאנחנו יכולים למעשה
למנף את כל מה שאנחנו יודעים על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים במרדף אחר יתרונות חישוביים קוונטיים.
המחשבים הקלאסיים שיש לנו היום הם באמת פלאי טכנולוגיה.
הם מהירים להפליא, אבל הם לא כל כך מהירים שאף בעיה חישובית
לא מעבר להישג ידם.
בעיות חישוביות מסוימות
כל כך קשות מטבען שלמרות שיש לנו
אלגוריתמים לפתור אותן, אף מחשב על כדור הארץ היום
לא מהיר מספיק להריץ את
האלגוריתמים האלה עד תום גם על קלטים בגודל בינוני בתוך משך חיי אדם
או אפילו בתוך משך
חיי כדור הארץ עצמו.
כדי להסביר יותר, בואו נסתכל על
בעיית הפירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים.
הגדרת הבעיה מאוד פשוטה. הקלט לבעיה הוא מספר שלם N שהוא לפחות שתיים, והפלט הוא
הפירוק לגורמים ראשוניים של N,
ומה שזה אומר הוא רשימה של הגורמים הראשוניים של N יחד עם החזקות שצריך להעלות את המספרים הראשוניים האלה
כדי לקבל את N על ידי
הכפלת כולם יחד.
כמובן, אנחנו תמיד יכולים להכפיל את הגורמים הראשוניים יחד בכל סדר, אבל מלבד הסדר שלהם,
פירוקים לגורמים ראשוניים תמיד ייחודיים לכל בחירה של N.
העובדה הזו נקראת
המשפט היסודי של האריתמטיקה, ואם אתם מעוניינים
ללמוד עוד על זה, זה משהו שאפשר למצוא
בתחילת
ספרים רבים על תורת המספרים.
כדוגמה מאוד פשוטה, הנה הפירוק לגורמים ראשוניים
של המספר 12.
זה שתיים בחזקת שתיים
כפול שלוש בחזקת אחד.
לא מפתיע שמחשב
יכול לספר לך את זה בהרף עין על ידי חיפוש
איטרטיבי פשוט של גורמים ראשוניים.
הנה דוגמה נוספת. אני לא אנסה לקרוא את המספר הזה.
זה בערך 3.4 קוואטואורדציליון, ואני חייב להודות שאני מוצא את זה מוזר שיש בכלל שם כזה,
אבל בכל מקרה, יש לו 46 ספרות עשרוניות וכאן אפשר לראות
את הפירוק לגורמים ראשוניים שלו.
מחשב יכול לספר לך את זה גם. פירקתי את המספר הזה באמצעות שיטת הפירוק שכלולה בספריית המתמטיקה הסימבולית
של Python,
וזה לקח כמה שניות, מה שזה לא זמן ארוך במיוחד, אבל הייתה עיכוב מורגש.
ובוודאי ששיטת factor N לא מוצאת את הפירוק לגורמים ראשוניים הזה על ידי חיפוש נאיבי של גורמים ראשוניים.
היא בעצם משתמשת בשילוב
של אלגוריתמים שונים כולל אחד שנקרא
אלגוריתם colored row, שהוא אלגוריתם לפירוק
שמתוחכם יותר מחיפוש נאיבי איטרטיבי
של גורמים ראשוניים, ולמרות שזה אולי נראה
כמו מספר די גדול,
כקלט לבעיה חישובית, הוא לא באמת כל כך גדול בכלל.
יש לו רק 46 תווים.
הנה עוד דוגמה. זה מספר עם 309 ספרות עשרוניות.
אם נכתוב אותו בייצוג בינארי, יש לו 1,024 ביטים וזו
הסיבה שהוא נקרא RSA1024.
הפירוק לגורמים ראשוניים של המספר הזה לא ידוע כרגע.
המספר הזה מגיע מאתגר
הפירוק של RSA, שנוהל על ידי RSA
Laboratories מ-1991 עד 2007.
הם הציעו פרסי כסף
על פירוקים לגורמים ראשוניים של מספרים שונים בגדלים
הולכים וגדלים, כולל המספר הזה, ששווה היה 100,000 דולר אמריקאי,
אבל הפרס הזה מעולם לא נגבה.
האבטחה של מערכת ההצפנה
בעלת מפתח ציבורי RSA מבוססת על הקושי
של פירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים.
אם אתה יכול לפרק לגורמים,
אתה יכול לשבור את המערכת, ולכן מטרת האתגר הייתה בעצם לעקוב אחרי
הטכנולוגיה המתקדמת ביותר בפירוק לגורמים.
השורה התחתונה היא שפירוק
המספר הזה הוא מעבר ליכולות הנוכחיות שלנו.
ככל שידוע לנו, הבעיה
עצמה מורכבת מדי למחשבים קלאסיים
כדי לפתור בפועל.
מספר האתגר הגדול ביותר של RSA שפורק לגורמים עד כה, אגב, הוא בעל 250 ספרות עשרוניות.
אולי קצת קשה
לקרוא את זה על המסך, אבל הנה הפירוק
לגורמים ראשוניים של RSA250.
זה נעשה ב-2020 באמצעות אלגוריתם הידוע בשם הנפה של שדות מספרים, והיה מאמץ קולקטיבי שכלל עשרות אלפי
מחשבים ברחבי העולם.
עכשיו, בואו נשקול בעיה
חישובית אחרת, שהיא הבעיה של חישוב המחלק המשותף
הגדול ביותר, או GCD בקיצור,
של שני מספרים שלמים לא שליליים.
הנה ניסוח הבעיה. הקלט מורכב משני
מספרים הפעם, N ו-M,
ואנחנו הולכים להניח
שהם לא שניהם שווים לאפס.
המטרה היא לחשב את
ה-GCD של שני המספרים האלה, שהוא המספר השלם הגדול ביותר D שמחלק בצורה שווה גם את N וגם את M,
ואם חושבים על הפירוקים
לגורמים ראשוניים של N ו-M, מה שתמצאו הוא שה-GCD הוא המכפלה של כל המספרים הראשוניים
שמחלקים גם את N וגם את M מורמים למינימום של החזקות שמופיעות בשני
הפירוקים לגורמים ראשוניים.
אז זה קשור לבעיה
של פירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים, אבל מתברר שזה הרבה, הרבה יותר קל
למחשבים לפתור. אנחנו יכולים לחשב GCD עבור מספרים עם אלפי ספרות רבות
בהרף עין.
זה קצת חסר טעם בשבילי לנסות להראות לכם דוגמאות על המסך כי יכולנו למלא את
כל המסך בספרות ועדיין היינו מתארים
מופעים קלים לפתרון של הבעיה הזו.
אבל אם אתם מעוניינים, עקבו אחר הקישור בתיאור הסרטון לדף הספר הלימודי של השיעור הזה ותמצאו תאי קוד
לסוגי החישובים
שאני מדבר עליהם, כולל כאלה שמחשבים
GCD של מספרים גדולים, ואתם יכולים לנסות אותם בעצמכם.
השאלה היא למה אפשר לחשב GCD בקלות כזו?
והתשובה לשאלה הזו היא שיש לנו אלגוריתמים
יעילים לחישוב GCD.
ביניהם האלגוריתם של Euclid, שהתגלה לפני יותר מ-2,000 שנה, אבל יש גם
אלגוריתמי GCD יעילים אחרים.
וכמובן אנחנו מדברים על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים כאן, אז זה מוביל לשאלה נוספת.
האם ייתכן שקיים אלגוריתם
קלאסי יעיל לפירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים
שיאפשר לנו לפרק מספרים כמו RSA1024
בהרף עין?
והתשובה היא כן. בהחלט ייתכן שיש אלגוריתם קלאסי
יעיל לפירוק לגורמים וכרגע אנחנו לא מכירים שום דרך
לשלול את האפשרות הזו. כל מה שאנחנו יכולים לומר הוא
שעדיין לא מצאנו כזה.
בכל אלגוריתמי הפירוק
הקלאסיים שאנחנו מכירים, אנחנו עדיין בעצם
מחפשים גורמים
וזה מציב מספרים כמו
RSA1024 מעבר להישג ידינו.
אלגוריתמי GCD יעילים,
מצד שני, פשוט לא עובדים ככה.
הם לא מחפשים מחלק
משותף גדול ביותר. הם למעשה פשוט בונים
אותו עם הליך מכני שעלותו דומה בערך
להכפלת אותם
שני מספרים יחד, ואספר עוד קצת על זה בהמשך השיעור.
כמובן, כל זה מוביל
לאלגוריתם של Shor, שנראה בשיעור הבא, שהוא אלגוריתם קוונטי יעיל
לחישוב פירוקים לגורמים ראשוניים, אבל עוד יש לנו קצת דרך
לעבור לפני שנגיע לשם.
בהמשך נדבר
על מסגרת מתמטית שדרכה נוכל למדוד את העלויות החישוביות
של אלגוריתמים שונים,
כולל כאלה שכבר דיברנו עליהם.
ליתר דיוק, אנחנו הולכים להתמקד באופן צר מאוד ב-circuit, שזה רק חלק קטן
מנושא הרבה יותר רחב.
בואו נתחיל עם תמונה ברמה גבוהה מאוד של חישוב רגיל
מהשיעור הקודם, כלומר במיוחד שאנחנו לא חושבים
על בעיות שאילתה,
אנחנו חושבים על
בעיות שבהן הקלט ניתן במפורש כמחרוזת בינארית.
כמו שאמרתי בשיעור הקודם, כמובן שיכולנו לאפשר
סמלים אחרים אם רצינו, אבל בואו פשוט נשמור על דברים פשוטים ונישאר עם מחרוזות בינאריות
גם לקלט וגם לפלט.
את החישוב עצמו אפשר לדגם או לתאר במגוון דרכים כמו עם מודל
מכונת Turing של חישוב,
circuit בוליאניים, circuit קוונטיים, או תוכניות שנכתבו
בשפה כמו Python או כל שפה אחרת שתבחרו.
כמו שאמרתי לפני רגע, אנחנו הולכים להתמקד
ב-circuit, בוליאניים וקוונטיים.
קודם, בואו נקדיש עוד קצת זמן לדבר על הקלט והפלט, שאנחנו מניחים שהם מחרוזות בינאריות.
באמצעות מחרוזות בינאריות, אפשר לקודד סוגים רבים ושונים של
עצמים מתמטיים, כמו מספרים, וקטורים,
מטריצות, גרפים,
תיאורים של מולקולות, למשל, וכן רשימות של כל העצמים האלה ואחרים.
כדוגמה מאוד פשוטה, אם אנחנו רוצים לקודד מספרים שלמים
לא שליליים כמחרוזות בינאריות, אפשר להשתמש בייצוג בינארי.
כאן בטבלה הזו, תראו את 13
המספרים השלמים הלא שליליים הראשונים יחד עם הייצוגים
או הקידודים הבינאריים שלהם.
כאן בעמודה השלישית, אפשר לראות את האורך של
כל אחד מהקידודים האלה, שהוא פשוט מספר הביטים הכולל שצריך לקידוד,
והנה נוסחה פשוטה שאומרת לכם בדיוק כמה ביטים
צריך באופן כללי לכל מספר שלם לא שלילי N.
שימו לב במיוחד שאורך
הקידוד בדרך כלל הרבה יותר קטן
מהמספר עצמו.
הוא לוגריתמי במספר.
RSA1024 למשל, יש לו קידוד באורך 1,024, אבל המספר עצמו כמובן
הרבה יותר גדול מזה.
סכמת הקידוד הזו עובדת
למספרים שלמים לא שליליים, אבל אם רוצים לטפל
במספרים שלמים שרירותיים, כולל שליליים,
אפשר פשוט להוסיף ביט סימן.
אפשר גם לאפשר כל מספר של אפסים מובילים בקידודים האלה אם רוצים שהקידודים
ימלאו בלוק של ביטים או רגיסטר בגודל קבוע
כל עוד הוא מספיק גדול. לפעמים זה מאוד נוח.
זו לא הדרך היחידה לקודד מספרים שלמים כמחרוזות של ביטים.
יש דרכים אחרות שאפשר לעשות את זה, אבל זו דרך
די סטנדרטית לעשות את זה.
לסוגים אחרים של עצמים שעלולים להוות את הקלטים או הפלטים לבעיות
חישוביות שמעניינות אותנו, אפשר לחשוב על
סכמות קידוד אחרות.
למשל, חשבו על איך
אפשר לקודד וקטור או גרף כמחרוזת בינארית או חשבו על איך אפשר לקודד
שתי מחרוזות בינאריות
למחרוזת בינארית אחת באמצעות רק הסמלים אפס ואחד בלי רווח או כל סמל אחר
כדי להפריד בין שתי המחרוזות. בהחלט יש דרכים
לעשות את הדברים האלה, ולמעשה, יש לנו הרבה חופש
לגבי איך בדיוק אנחנו עושים את זה.
לעתים קרובות לא תהיה דרך סטנדרטית אחת או מוסכמת באופן אוניברסלי לקודד את מה שאנחנו מדברים
עליו כמחרוזת בינארית,
אבל זה בסדר, אנחנו יכולים פשוט לבחור אחת או להמציא חדשה אם אנחנו מעדיפים.
מנקודת מבט פורמלית גרידא, אנחנו חושבים על חישובים כטרנספורמציות מכניות בעצם על מחרוזות של ביטים
והפרטים של סכמות
הקידוד שאנחנו משתמשים בהן בהחלט חשובים ברמה מסוימת.
אבל בכל זאת, כשאנחנו מתכננים
ומנתחים אלגוריתמים, בדרך כלל לא מדאיגים אותנו כל כך הפרטים של
סכמות הקידוד.
אם תבקשו משני אנשים שונים לחשוב על דרך לקודד, נגיד, מולקולות מסוג
מסוים כמחרוזות בינאריות,
אפשר לצפות שהם יעלו על דרכים שונות לעשות את זה, אבל אם אלה היו אנשים סבירים שיודעים מה הם עושים,
אפשר גם לצפות באופן סביר שזה יהיה תהליך חישובי
פשוט למדי לתרגם הלוך ושוב בין שתי סכמות הקידוד,
שכנראה ידרוש חישוב
פשוט למדי שיהיה די קל בהשוואה לחישוב
האמיתי שמעניין אותנו.
השורה התחתונה היא שהפרטים הנוגעים לסכמות הקידוד שאנחנו משתמשים בהן הם לעתים קרובות די משניים והמיקוד שלנו הוא על
האלגוריתמים עצמם.
שום דבר מזה לא יהיה בעיה בשיעור הזה, אגב. בעיקר נתמקד בבעיות שנוגעות למספרים שלמים, שנניח שהם מקודדים בבינארי,
אבל זה משהו שכדאי להיות מודעים אליו.
באופן כללי, לכל סוג של בעיה שאנחנו מדברים עליה, אורך הקלט מתייחס
למספר הביטים שצריך כדי לקודד את הקלט,
ואנחנו רואים את אורך הקלט כגודל של המופע של כל בעיה שאנחנו חושבים עליה.
עכשיו, בואו נשקול
את החישוב עצמו, שמיוצג על ידי
המלבן הכחול באיור הזה.
הדרך שבה נמדוד
את עלות החישוב הזה היא לספור את מספר הפעולות האלמנטריות שהוא דורש.
באופן אינטואיטיבי, פעולה אלמנטרית היא כזו שמערבת מספר קבוע קטן
של ביטים או qubit-ים
שאפשר לבצע אותה מהר ובקלות כמו חישוב AND של
שני ביטים, למשל.
ברמה הפורמלית,
יש דרכים שונות להגדיר מהי פעולה אלמנטרית, בהתאם למודל
החישובי שאנחנו משתמשים בו.
למשל, פעולה אלמנטרית יכולה להיות צעד אחד של מכונת Turing אם השתמשנו במודל הזה.
למטרות השיעור הזה, אנחנו הולכים להתמקד במודלים של circuit, כפי שכבר ציינתי, ובמיוחד circuit קוונטיים
ובוליאניים.
כשעובדים עם circuit, מקובל שחושבים על כל gate כמייצג פעולה אלמנטרית.
ראינו כמה gate-ים קוונטיים שונים עד כה בסדרה,
כולל gate-ים X, Y ו-Z, gate-ים Hadamard, gate-ים S ו-T,
gate-ים controlled NOT, gate-ים swap, gate-ים Toffoli ו-gate-ים Fredkin.
דיברנו גם על query gate-ים בהקשר של מודל השאילתות, אבל אנחנו לא הולכים לעבוד בתוך מודל השאילתות בשיעור הזה, אז לא נדאג לגבי
query gate-ים לעת עתה.
ראינו גם שכל פעולה יוניטרית על כל מספר של qubit-ים
אפשר לראות כ-gate אם רוצים לעשות את זה.
אבל למטרות מדידת עלות, זה לא יהיה מאוד מועיל, אז מה שנעשה הוא פשוט
לבחור קבוצה של gate-ים
ונראה בקבוצה הזו את קבוצת הפעולות האלמנטריות שלנו.
ראשית, נכלול את
gate-ים היוניטריים על qubit יחיד שאתם רואים כאן,
כלומר gate-ים X, Y ו-Z,
gate-ים Hadamard ו-gate-ים S ו-T, וכן את ההפכיים שלהם
או הצמדים הטרנספוזיים.
בעצם לא צריך את כל ה-gate-ים האלה. ברגע שיש לנו gate-ים Hadamard ו-T, אפשר ליישם את כל השאר,
אבל רק למען הנוחות, אנחנו הולכים לכלול את כולם.
נכלול גם gate-ים controlled NOT, ואלה יהיו
ה-gate-ים היחידים על מספר qubit-ים בקבוצה שלנו.
ולבסוף נכלול מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי על qubit יחיד כדי שנוכל באמת לקבל מידע קלאסי
שיוצא מה-circuit שלנו.
אם נתמקד רק ב-gate-ים היוניטריים ונשכח מהמדידות
לרגע, נקבל מה שנקרא
קבוצת gate-ים אוניברסלית.
מה שזה אומר הוא שכל
פעולה יוניטרית על כל מספר של qubit-ים יכולה
להיות מיושמת בדיוק
או בקירוב שרירותי
עם circuit קוונטי שבנוי רק מה-gate-ים האלה.
במילים אחרות, זו קבוצת
gate-ים מספיק טובה כדי שנוכל לבנות כל פעולה
יוניטרית מהם.
לא בהכרח בדיוק, אבל אפשר לקבל קירוב
טוב ככל שנרצה.
זה יכול לדרוש הרבה gate-ים, ולמעשה לא קשה מדי להסיק שזה חייב לדרוש
הרבה gate-ים לפעמים,
אבל בכל זאת, זה תמיד אפשרי.
זה לא עניין פשוט להוכיח שזו קבוצת gate-ים אוניברסלית, ולא נדון באיך
שזה נעשה בסדרה,
אבל זו עובדה מוכרת למדי ויש למעשה דרכים שונות
שאפשר להוכיח אותה.
יש גם קבוצות gate-ים אחרות שלפעמים משתמשים בהן
במקום זו, כמו gate-ים Toffoli, gate-ים Hadamard ו-gate-ים S בנוסף למדידות,
אבל זו בחירה די סטנדרטית.
אז לסיכום, אלה הפעולות
הקוונטיות שנראה כאלמנטריות.
עבור circuit בוליאניים,
אנחנו הולכים להתייחס לארבעת ה-gate-ים האלה
כפעולות אלמנטריות: gate-ים AND, gate-ים OR, gate-ים NOT ו-FANOUT.
FANOUT, אגב, לא
תמיד נספר כ-gate, אבל זה יהיה
חשוב לנו לעשות את זה כפי שנראה בהמשך השיעור.
בדומה למה שהיה לנו עבור
קבוצת ה-gate הקוונטית הסטנדרטית שלנו, הקבוצה הזו קצת מיותרת.
לא צריך גם AND וגם OR. אפשר ליצור כל אחד מהם באמצעות האחר עם שלושה gate-ים NOT,
אבל לא מזיק לכלול את שניהם וזה פשוט נוח.
כפי שאולי כבר ידוע לכם, זו קבוצת gate-ים אוניברסלית
לחישובים דטרמיניסטיים, כלומר כל פונקציה
מביטים לביטים
יכולה להיות מיושמת עם circuit בוליאני שמורכב מ-gate-ים מהאוסף הזה.
שוב, בדיוק כמו שהיה
לנו עבור circuit קוונטיים, זה לא אומר שכל פונקציה ניתנת ליישום יעיל
על ידי circuit בוליאני,
ואכן רוב הפונקציות
ניתנות ליישום רק עם circuit-ים גדולים מאוד
מהסיבה הפשוטה שיש המון פונקציות
ולא לכולן יכולים להיות circuit-ים קטנים. פשוט אין מספיק
circuit-ים קטנים לכולם.
אוניברסליות קלה יותר
להוכחה במקרה הזה מאשר במקרה הקוונטי כפי שמתברר.
אז אם אתם עדיין לא
יודעים איך להוכיח את זה, תנו לזה מחשבה
ותראו אם אתם יכולים להבין את זה אם אתם נוטים לכך.
עכשיו שהחלטנו על
ה-gate-ים שאנחנו הולכים לאפשר ושאנחנו הולכים להתייחס
אליהם כפעולות אלמנטריות, אפשר לחשוב על כמה מהם
נדרשים כדי לבצע
חישובים שונים.
כדי לעשות את זה, נשתמש
בהגדרה הזו לגודל של circuit.
ההגדרה הזו עובדת גם עבור
circuit בוליאניים וגם קוונטיים והיא מאוד פשוטה.
הגודל של circuit הוא מספר
ה-gate-ים הכולל שיש בו.
למשל, אם נחזור
לאותה דוגמה שראינו כמה פעמים, שהיא ה-circuit הבוליאני שלנו לחישוב XOR של שני ביטים,
רואים שהגודל שלו הוא שבע
כי יש שבעה gate-ים, שני gate-ים FANOUT, שני gate-ים NOT,
שני gate-ים AND ו-gate OR אחד. אם החלטנו לא לספור
gate-ים FANOUT, מה שנפוץ, הגודל שלו היה חמש,
אבל אנחנו כן סופרים gate-ים FANOUT, אז הגודל שלו הוא שבע.
הגודל של circuit
מתאים למספר הפעולות האלמנטריות
שצריך לבצע.
אז אם היינו מבצעים
את הפעולות האלה ברצף והגודל היה אומר
לנו כמה זמן זה ייקח,
אז אפשר לחשוב על גודל circuit כמייצג זמן ריצה סדרתי.
ככה אנחנו הולכים
למדוד עלות חישובית למטרות השיעור הזה.
יש עוד תכונה של
circuit שגם אפשר לראות בה את כמות הזמן
הנדרשת להרצת circuit, וזו העומק של ה-circuit.
ליתר דיוק, העומק
הוא מספר ה-gate-ים המקסימלי שנתקלים בו בכל מסלול מחוט קלט לחוט פלט,
מה שמקביל למספר השכבות של gate-ים שצריך
כדי ליצור את ה-circuit, כאשר שכבה מתייחסת לחבורה של gate-ים
שאפשר לבצע אותם בו-זמנית כי אין
להם חוטים משותפים.
למשל, ה-circuit שלנו
מקודם יש לו עומק ארבע, ואפשר לראות ישירות מהתרשים שיש ארבע שכבות.
gate-ים FANOUT אפשר
לבצע בו-זמנית, gate-ים NOT אפשר
לבצע בו-זמנית ו-gate-ים AND אפשר
לבצע בו-זמנית גם כן.
אז אפשר לחשוב על עומק circuit כמייצג זמן ריצה מקבילי.
עומק circuit הוא בהחלט מושג מעניין וחשוב ויש כמה טכניקות
מתוחכמות מאוד שאפשר להשתמש בהן כדי להפחית
את העומק הנדרש לחישובים מסוימים, לפעמים באופן דרמטי למדי, למעשה, אבל זה נושא מתקדם
ולא יהיה לנו הרבה יותר מה לומר על זה בסדרה הזו.
אז שוב, נמדוד
עלות חישובית במונחים של גודל
circuit או במילים אחרות,
מספר הפעולות האלמנטריות הנדרשות לביצוע חישוב.
בתחילת השיעור, דיברנו על בעיית
הפירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים וראינו שהזמן הנדרש לאלגוריתם כדי לפתור את הבעיה הזו
יכול לגדול ככל שהקלטים גדלים באורכם, וזה בדרך כלל
הנושא שאנחנו מתמקדים בו
כשאנחנו מנתחים אלגוריתמים.
כלומר, אנחנו מתעניינים באיך שהעלויות של הרצת אלגוריתמים מתרחבות ככל שהקלטים נהיים גדולים יותר ויותר.
כמובן, סוג כזה של התרחבות הוא לא הדבר היחיד שמשנה.
למשל, אולי אנחנו פשוט מעוניינים למצוא את הגורמים
של RSA1024 וזהו.
אז במקרה כזה, היינו מדברים על
מופע בעיה בודד שבו שום דבר לא גדל.
אבל כשחושבים על אלגוריתמים, האופן שבו העלויות שלהם
מתרחבות משנה מאוד והוא אומר לנו הרבה
על האלגוריתמים.
נקודת המבט הזו
עקבית עם הרעיון שאלגוריתמים הם יסודיים, וכפי שדיברתי קודם,
ככל שהזמן עובר והטכנולוגיה מתקדמת, הם ייפרסו על
קלטים גדולים יותר ויותר.
אבל שימו לב שבעוד שקלטים לבעיות חישוביות
יכולים לגדול בגודלם, circuit-ים לא גדלים.
לכל circuit יש גודל קבוע.
ומהסיבה הזו, אם רוצים לתאר
אלגוריתם באמצעות circuit-ים, אנחנו בעצם צריכים משפחה של circuit-ים לעשות את זה,
ובמשפחה של circuit-ים הכוונה לאוסף של circuit-ים שהולך וגדל כדי שנוכל להתאים קלטים
ככל שהם הולכים וגדלים. למשל, בואו נשקול אלגוריתם דטרמיניסטי קלאסי
לבעיית הפירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים, אולי כזה שמבוסס על חלוקת ניסיון, אבל הפרטים לא באמת משנים
לצורך הדוגמה הזו.
אנחנו יכולים בעיקרון
לתאר אלגוריתם כזה באמצעות משפחה של circuit-ים בוליאניים שבה אם רוצים לפרק מספר
שהייצוג הבינארי שלו הוא בן N ביטים, אנחנו לוקחים את ה-circuit CN מהמשפחה שלנו ומזינים את המספר
שאנחנו רוצים לפרק
לביטי הקלט של ה-circuit הזה.
לפעמים נבחר לפרמטר את
ה-circuit-ים האלה בדרכים שונות, אז לא תמיד יהיה המצב שה-circuit ה-N-י יש לו N ביטי קלט,
אבל זו דרך די טיפוסית לעשות את זה. באופן טבעי, ככל שאורכי הקלט
מתארכים, היינו מצפים שה-circuit-ים
במשפחה הזו יגדלו
מה שמשקף את העובדה
שפירוק מספרים בני ארבעה ביטים הוא הרבה יותר קל מפירוק מספרים בני 1,024 ביטים, למשל.
ולכן, עם זה בראש, אנחנו מודדים את עלות אלגוריתם
כזה באמצעות פונקציה, שאומרת לנו כמה
פעולות אלמנטריות
אנחנו צריכים לכל אורך קלט אפשרי, ואפשר לעשות את זה גם לאלגוריתמים קלאסיים וגם קוונטיים.
כדוגמה, בואו נשקול את בעיית חיבור מספרים שלמים, שבהחלט הרבה
יותר פשוטה מפירוק לגורמים
או אפילו מחישוב GCD.
רק כדי לשמור על דברים פשוטים, נניח שגם N וגם
M הם מספרים שלמים לא שליליים ושהם מיוצגים
על ידי מחרוזות בינאריות באותו אורך.
איך נוכל לבנות circuit-ים בוליאניים שמחברים את שני המספרים האלה יחד?
ובכן, בואו נתחיל עם אלגוריתם, האלגוריתם הסטנדרטי לחיבור, שהוא האנלוג בבסיס שתיים של השיטה
שאני מניח שכולנו למדנו לחבר מספרים יחד עם
עיפרון ופיסת נייר, אז מתחילים עם הביטים
הכי פחות משמעותיים,
מחברים אותם יחד, וזה נותן לנו את הביט
הכי פחות משמעותי של התוצאה יחד עם ביט נשא
שצריך להתחשב בו
כשעוברים לעמדה הבאה. ואנחנו ממשיכים לעבור דרך הביטים, מייצרים ביטי פלט
יחד עם ביטי נשא
עד שמגיעים לסוף.
את השיטה הזו אפשר
לבטא ישירות למדי במונחים של circuit-ים בוליאניים.
דרך אחת לחשוב על זה היא להתחיל עם circuit קטן לחיבור שני מספרים שלמים בני ביט אחד.
זה ייתן לנו מספר
בין אפס לשתיים, כאשר הביט הפחות משמעותי הוא ה-XOR של ביטי הקלט
והביט היותר משמעותי, או ביט הנשא אם תרצו, הוא ה-AND של שני ביטי הקלט.
לפעמים מתייחסים ל-circuit שמבצע את שתי
הפעולות האלה יחד כחצי-מחבר.
זה עובד יפה כשיש
רק שני ביטי קלט, אבל אם רוצים לחבר יחד מספרים שלמים עם יותר מביט אחד כל אחד,
נצטרך להתמודד
עם ביטי הנשא איכשהו.
אז מה שאפשר לעשות הוא לשרשר
שני חצאי-מחברים יחד ולקחת את ה-OR של
ביטי הנשא שהם מייצרים כדי ליצור מה שנקרא מחבר מלא,
שהוא בעצם circuit בוליאני לחיבור שלושה מספרים
בני ביט אחד.
וברגע שיש לנו מחבר מלא, אפשר לחבר מספרים
פשוט על ידי שרשור, מהביט הכי פחות משמעותי
לביט המשמעותי ביותר. בעצם אנחנו פשוט מיישמים את אלגוריתם החיבור הסטנדרטי באמצעות המחברים המלאים כדי
לטפל בביטי הנשא.
אז מהי עלות החישוב הזה?
ובכן, צריך שבעה gate-ים
אלמנטריים לכל gate XOR, מה שאומר 10 gate-ים לחצי-מחבר
ולכן 21 gate-ים למחבר מלא, שהוא שני חצאי-מחברים ועוד gate OR.
אז בסוף, אם מספרי הקלט שלנו שניהם בני N ביטים, צריך חצי-מחבר עבור
הביט הכי פחות משמעותי
ומחבר מלא לכל ביט אחר, והתוצאה הסופית היא 21 כפול N פחות אחד ועוד 10 או 21N פחות 11 gate-ים בסך הכל.
אם החלטנו מסיבה כלשהי שלא רוצים
לספור gate-ים FANOUT וכללנו את gate-ים
XOR בקבוצת ה-gate שלנו, היינו צריכים 5N פחות
שלושה gate-ים בסך הכל.
זה נחמד לדעת בדיוק כמה gate-ים או פעולות אלמנטריות נדרשות לביצוע חישובים שונים,
כמו שזה עתה ראינו עם חיבור מספרים שלמים.
וכמובן, אם אנחנו באמת רוצים ליישם את החישובים האלה, צריך לדעת את הפרטים האלה.
אבל אם תמיד ניכנס לפרטים ברמה כזו, במיוחד עבור אלגוריתמים
מורכבים יותר, נהיה מהר מאוד שקועים בפרטים
שבמקרים רבים חשיבותם
משנית.
דרך אחת לפשט את העניינים שמאוד נפוצה בניתוח
של אלגוריתמים היא להשתמש בסימון big-O,
שמאפשר לנו לבטא
ולהשוות קצבי גדילה בצורה פשוטה למדי
שמאוד נוחה.
וכאן אפשר לראות את ההגדרה שמאחורי הסימון הזה.
נניח שיש לנו
שתי פונקציות G ו-H, שאפשר לחשוב עליהן כמקבלות ערכים של מספרים שלמים
לא שליליים לשם פשטות,
אם כי זה לא באמת נדרש. אולי G ו-H מייצגים עלויות של חישובים שונים, למשל.
אנחנו אומרים ש-G הוא big-O של H, מה שמסורתית נכתב
עם סימן שוויון כמו כאן.
אם G של N הוא לכל היותר קבוע
חיובי C כפול H של N, כל עוד N גדול מספיק.
אז זה על מה שקורה
כש-N נהיה גדול.
פורמלית, מה שגדול מספיק אומר הוא שיש בחירה כלשהי של N אפס כך שאי השוויון נכון
בכל פעם ש-N הוא לפחות N אפס.
המפתח כאן הוא שהמספרים
C ו-N אפס קבועים.
הם יכולים להיות כל מספרים
שהם, אבל מה שהם לא יהיו, הם לא יכולים להשתנות ככל ש-N גדל.
אם לא ראיתם סוג כזה
של הגדרה בעבר, ייתכן שייקח קצת זמן להתרגל אליה ואפשר למצוא משאבים
שיסבירו את המושג הזה
בהרבה יותר פירוט
ממה שאני מסוגל בשיעור הזה.
בדרך כלל מה שעושים הוא לבחור
את הפונקציה H להיות פשוטה כדי לבטא משהו על כמה מהר הפונקציה G גדלה.
למשל, הפונקציה שערכה הוא 17 כפול N בשלישית פחות 257
כפול N בריבוע ועוד
65,537 היא big-O של N בשלישית, ואפשר להתאים את הדוגמה
הזו להגדרה
על ידי בחירה מתאימה של C ו-N אפס.
למשל, אם ניקח C להיות 18, אז יהיה לנו שהביטוי
הוא אכן לכל היותר 18 כפול N בשלישית
כל עוד N גדול מספיק.
אם נקשור את הסימון הזה בחזרה
לדוגמה של חיבור מספרים שלמים, מה שאפשר עכשיו לומר הוא שקיימת משפחה של circuit-ים בוליאניים
לחיבור מספרים שלמים לא שליליים כך שהגודל של ה-circuit ה-N-י, כלומר זה שעובד
עבור קלטים באורך N
הוא big-O של N. הגודל האמיתי של CN
לפי הניתוח שלנו היה 21 כפול N פחות 11,
אבל זה big-O של N.
עכשיו זה לא תמיד דבר חכם לזרוק פרטים כאלה, אבל כאן זה הגיוני
כי זה חושף את המהות של אלגוריתם החיבור הסטנדרטי, שהיא שהעלות שלו מתרחבת באופן ליניארי
בגודל המספרים
שאנחנו מחברים יחד, והביטוי הזה לא רגיש לחלק מהפרטים ברמה נמוכה
של המודל שלנו,
כמו בדיוק אילו gate-ים אנחנו מחשיבים כפעולות אלמנטריות.
למשל, אם החלטנו ש-gate-ים XOR צריכים להיחשב
כפעולות אלמנטריות או ש-gate-ים FANOUT לא צריכים
להיספר כ-gate-ים או שניהם,
עדיין היה לנו שחיבור מספרים שלמים ניתן לחישוב בעלות big-O של N.
הנה דוגמה נוספת של
בעיה חישובית, הכפלת מספרים שלמים.
בדומה לחיבור, אפשר לשאול מהי עלות
החישוב הזה.
אם נשקול את אלגוריתם
ההכפלה הסטנדרטי, כלומר האנלוג בבסיס שתיים של השיטה להכפלת מספרים
שנלמדת בבתי ספר יסודיים,
שהיא בעצם רק
הזזה וחיבור כשעובדים עם מספרים בבינארי, נמצא שיש circuit-ים בוליאניים בגודל big-O של N בריבוע
להכפלת מספרים שלמים בני N ביטים.
לא אפרט את זה. כמובן שה-circuit-ים קצת
יותר מורכבים מאלה שלחיבור, אבל אם חושבים על הדרך
שבה אלגוריתם ההכפלה
הסטנדרטי עובד, זה לא אמור להיות הפתעה.
בעצם, צריך
לעשות בערך N חיבורים, כל אחד בעלות ליניארית, ואז מגיעים לעלות
ריבועית בסך הכל.
אפשר להכליל את זה. אם למספר אחד יש N ביטים ולשני יש M ביטים, אז צריך circuit-ים בגודל
big-O של N כפול M.
כאן, אגב, אנחנו משתמשים בהרחבה של סימון big-O שבו יש כמה משתנים, אבל אפשר להרחיב אותו ככה,
ואם אתם מעוניינים
בפרטים הספציפיים, אפנה אתכם לתוכן
הספר הלימודי של השיעור, שוב מקושר
בתיאור הסרטון.
למעשה אפשר
להכפיל שני מספרים שלמים בני N ביטים בדרך
שעדיפה אסימפטוטית על אלגוריתם ההכפלה הסטנדרטי.
במיוחד, אלגוריתם ההכפלה של Schonhage-Strassen
מכפיל שני מספרים שלמים בני N ביטים בעלות של big-O של
N כפול אורך N
כפול אורך אורך N. אז ככל ש-N נהיה גדול, כמו
עשרות אלפי ביטים,
זו למעשה דרך יותר
יעילה להכפיל, אבל היא מסובכת והתקורה הופכת אותה ללא מעשית
למספרים קטנים יותר.
אז בואו נוסיף הכפלה
לרשימת הדוגמאות שלנו.
ורק לשם פשטות, נציין את העלות שניתנת על ידי אלגוריתם ההכפלה הסטנדרטי, שהיא big-O של N בריבוע.
אז שוב, אנחנו מתמקדים במהות של העלות הזו, שהיא שהיא מתרחבת באופן ריבועי
או תת-ריבועי אם משתמשים בשיטות עדיפות אסימפטוטית.
אפשר גם לשקול את
בעיית החלוקה של מספרים שלמים, שמנוסחת בדיוק על המסך.
כאן אנחנו מדברים על חישוב מנה ושארית, אז התשובה מורכבת
משני מספרים שלמים, Q ו-R.
שוב, יש אלגוריתם סטנדרטי
לחלוקה וגם לו יש עלות
ריבועית וכמו הכפלה,
יש למעשה אלגוריתמים
עדיפים אסימפטוטית.
אז איך אלגוריתמי GCD משתווים?
ובכן, לאלגוריתם של Euclid מתברר
שיש עלות ריבועית, וזה מה שהתכוונתי
קודם בשיעור כשאמרתי שאפשר לחשב GCD
בערך באותה עלות כמו הכפלת שני מספרים.
שוב, יש
אלגוריתמים עדיפים אסימפטוטית בקווים דומים
לחיבור והכפלה,
אם כי העלות קצת
גבוהה יותר במקרה הזה, לפחות ככל שידוע לנו.
אזכיר עוד דוגמה אחת של בעיה להוסיף לרשימה הזו, וזו העלאה מודולרית בחזקה.
כאן יש שלושה מספרי
קלט, K, M ו-N, והמטרה היא לחשב
N בחזקת K מודולו M,
מה שאומר השארית
אחרי שמחלקים ב-M.
זה בכלל לא ברור, אבל אפשר לחשב
העלאה מודולרית בחזקה בעלות קוביית, כלומר big-O של N בשלישית
למספרים שלמים בני N ביטים.
הדרך לעשות את זה היא לא לחשב קודם את N בחזקת K ואז לחשב את השארית.
אפילו לכתוב את N בחזקת K יכול לדרוש מספר אקספוננציאלי של ביטים, אז הגישה הזו לא תעבוד.
במקום זאת, אפשר להשתמש באלגוריתם
שנקרא אלגוריתם החזקה, שנקרא גם ריבוע חוזר שבו הכל נעשה מודולו M
ומשתמשים בביטים של
K כדי באופן איטרטיבי לרבע ולהכפיל בדרך
שגורמת לכל זה לעבוד.
אז הפעולה הזו יותר
יקרה מהאחרות, אבל עדיין אפשר לבצע
העלאה מודולרית בחזקה די מהר על מספרים
עם אלפי ביטים רבים.
אז איך העלויות של המשימות האלה משתוות עם פירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים?
אם נתחיל בפשטות
ונחשוב על חלוקת ניסיון שבה קודם בודקים אם שתיים הוא גורם של המספר
ואז בודקים שלוש וכן הלאה, נסיים עם אלגוריתם
די יקר, big-O של N בריבוע כפול
שתיים בחזקת N חלקי שתיים.
כל חלוקה לוקחת זמן ריבועי ובמקרה הגרוע ביותר, נצטרך לחפש גורמים ראשוניים עד השורש הריבועי של מספר הקלט,
ומשם מגיע ה-N
חלקי שתיים. אם לא מצאנו
גורם ראשוני בנקודה הזו, אפשר פשוט לעצור כי אז
מספר הקלט עצמו חייב להיות ראשוני.
זה יקר להפליא כי N מופיע כמעריך בביטוי הזה, כלומר
לאלגוריתם הזה יש עלות אקספוננציאלית.
לעומת זאת, כל הדוגמאות שיש לנו בתיבה הזו כאן הן בעלות מה שאנחנו קוראים לו עלות פולינומית שבה N מורם בחזקה,
אבל החזקה הזו תמיד מספר קבוע שלא גדל ככל
שאורך הקלט גדל.
במקרים האלה, החזקות
הן אחד, שתיים ושלוש.
אחזור לעלות פולינומית מול אקספוננציאלית בעוד רגע, אבל קודם, בואו נסיים את
מה שאנחנו יודעים על פירוק לגורמים.
קודם הזכרתי
את הנפה של שדה המספרים, שזה האלגוריתם הכי טוב לפירוק לגורמים שיש לנו מבחינת הדרך שבה העלות שלו גדלה.
למעשה, העלות של האלגוריתם הזה לא באמת הוכחה בצורה קפדנית כי היא קשורה לכמה שאלות פתוחות בתורת המספרים,
אבל משערים שיש לו
עלות שנראית ככה.
הפעם ה-big-O הוא במעריך, אבל אני הולך להעלים את הפרט הזה
מתחת לשטיח.
המסקנה המרכזית היא שזה משמעותית יותר טוב
מחילוק ניסיון כי למרות ש-N כן
מופיע במעריך,
הוא מועלה בחזקת 1/3 וזה מתורגם לעלות הרבה יותר נמוכה ולכן האלגוריתם הזה
מסוגל להתמודד עם מספרים כמו RSA250, בעוד שחילוק ניסיון
בהחלט לא יכול.
עדיין זה אקספוננציאלי במובן שחזקה של N מופיעה במעריך, ולכן, כתוצאה מכך,
הוא עדיין לא מסוגל להתמודד
עם מספרים כמו RSA1024.
עכשיו תנו לי להגיד עוד קצת על עלות פולינומית
לעומת עלות אקספוננציאלית.
אנחנו אומרים שלאלגוריתם
יש עלות פולינומית אם העלות שלו היא big-O של N בחזקת B,
כאשר B יכול להיות כל מספר חיובי, אבל המפתח הוא ש-B חייב להיות קבוע, כלומר הוא לא משתנה
ככל שאורך הקלט גדל.
בדוגמאות שראינו לפני רגע, כלומר חיבור מספרים שלמים, כפל, חילוק, חישוב מחלקים משותפים מקסימליים
והעלאה בחזקה מודולרית,
היה לנו ש-B היה או
אחד, שתיים או שלוש.
אז כולם אלגוריתמים
בעלות פולינומית.
אבל כשאנחנו אומרים עלות
פולינומית באופן כללי יותר, B יכול להיות כל מספר חיובי.
הוא אפילו יכול להיות מיליון,
אבל הוא חייב להיות קבוע.
כהפשטה מאוד גסה, אלגוריתמים בעלות פולינומית
בדרך כלל נתפסים כמייצגים אלגוריתמים יעילים.
זה בהחלט פישוט יתר, אבל כהנחיה גסה, אפשר לחשוב על אלגוריתם
בעלות פולינומית
כמשהו שמנצל את
המבנה של בעיה כדי לבנות פתרון, בניגוד לגישה מסוג כוח
גס
או חיפוש ממצה
על פני מרחב מאוד גדול.
כמובן, אלגוריתם שהעלות שלו גדלה כ-N בחזקת מיליון
על קלטים באורך N
לא היה נתפס באופן סביר
כיעיל, ולא היינו מצפים להיות
מסוגלים להריץ אותו על קלטים גדולים.
אבל עדיין גם אלגוריתם של N בחזקת
מיליון חייב לעשות משהו חכם שאיכשהו משקף את המבנה
של כל בעיה שהוא פותר כדי להימנע מהגדילה האקספוננציאלית בעלות שהייתה קשורה ל
חיפוש ממצה על פני תחום גדול.
ובפועל, הזיהוי של אלגוריתם בעלות פולינומית הוא באמת רק צעד ראשון
לקראת יעילות.
אם בעיה חשובה
ומישהו מגלה את האלגוריתם הפולינומי
הראשון עבורה, אולי עם מעריך מאוד גדול,
אפשר להיות בטוחים למדי שמתכנני אלגוריתמים
ימצאו שיפורים שיגרמו למעריך הזה לרדת.
בעיקרון, אפשר
לחשוב על הקיום של אלגוריתם בעלות פולינומית
לבעיה כהדגמה של הישימות
של פתרון הבעיה הזו
על קלטים גדולים למדי, אבל עדיין יכולה להיות הרבה עבודה נדרשת כדי להגיע ליעילות אמיתית.
בתורת הסיבוכיות, מקובל לומר שהעלות
של אלגוריתם גדלה תת-אקספוננציאלית אם העלות היא big-O של שתיים בחזקת N
בחזקת אפסילון לכל מספר ממשי חיובי אפסילון, ואם זה לא תת-אקספוננציאלי,
אז זה אקספוננציאלי, או שזה יכול אפילו להיות סופר-אקספוננציאלי כמו שתיים בחזקת שתיים בחזקת N,
שזה אקספוננציאלי כפול,
אבל כל עוד הפלט
לא ארוך באופן סופר-אקספוננציאלי, כל בעיה בעצם יכולה להיות
מחושבת על ידי circuit בוליאני
בעלות אקספוננציאלית כפי שמתברר. אז ההבחנה החשובה כאן היא בין עלות פולינומית
לעלות אקספוננציאלית.
אנחנו לא מכירים אלגוריתמים קלאסיים בעלות תת-אקספוננציאלית עבור
פירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים.
למשל, העלות של הנפה של שדה המספרים היא לא big-O של שתיים בחזקת
N בחזקת אפסילון כשאפסילון הוא 1/3 או פחות,
אז היא לא מקיימת את ההגדרה הזו.
זה ללא ספק אלגוריתם מאוד חכם, אבל הוא עדיין נפה ואנחנו עדיין למעשה מחפשים
על פני מרחב מאוד גדול כדי לזהות גורמים של מספר נתון.
כפי שנראה בשיעור הבא, יש למעשה אלגוריתם קוונטי בעלות פולינומית
לפירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים.
לאלגוריתם של Shor יש עלות פולינומית וספציפית יש לו עלות qubit, דומה להעלאה בחזקה מודולרית.
מחלקה נוספת של בעיות שאולי
אתם מכירים היא המחלקה של בעיות NP-שלמות.
אני לא אכנס למה זה בעיות NP-שלמות בשיעור הזה, אבל אתם יכולים לחפש
על זה אם זה מעניין אתכם.
משערים ש
לאף אחת מהבעיות האלה אין עלות תת-אקספוננציאלית.
זו בעצם גרסה מבוססת circuit של מה שלפעמים נקרא
השערת הזמן האקספוננציאלי, אבל עד עכשיו אף אחד לא הצליח
להוכיח את זה.
למעשה, אנחנו אפילו לא יכולים להוכיח שאין אלגוריתמים בעלות ליניארית לבעיות NP-שלמות.
זה פשוט ממש קשה, לפחות
ככל שאנחנו יודעים, לשלול את האפשרות
של גילוי עתידי של אלגוריתם
יצירתי להפליא לבעיות האלה.
הנה איור שממחיש
את הקשר בין עלות פולינומית לעלות אקספוננציאלית.
על ציר ה-X, יש לנו את אורך הקלט לכל בעיה שאנחנו חושבים עליה, וציר ה-Y מייצג את
העלות של פתרון הבעיה הזו
או אפשר לחשוב על
זה כזמן הנדרש לפתור את הבעיה אם אתם מעדיפים.
אלגוריתם בעלות אקספוננציאלית
עשוי לגדול ככה.
עבור קלטים קצרים, העלות אולי לא תהיה גבוהה במיוחד, כמו פירוק
המספר 12 לגורמים, למשל,
אבל ככל שאורך הקלט מתארך, העלות בסופו של דבר הולכת להתפוצץ.
אלגוריתם בעלות פולינומית,
מצד שני, עשוי לגדול בצורה שנראית ככה.
העלות עדיין תעלה באופן כללי ככל שהקלטים מתארכים, והיא אולי אפילו תעלה יותר מהאלגוריתם בעלות האקספוננציאלית
עבור חלק מהקלטים,
אבל בסופו של דבר זה הולך
להיות הרבה פחות יקר מהאלגוריתם בעלות האקספוננציאלית וזה לא מתפוצץ
באותה דרך קיצונית
שאלגוריתמים בעלות אקספוננציאלית כן.
אז אם נדמיין שיש לנו
עלות מקסימלית שאנחנו מוכנים להוציא, או כמות מקסימלית של זמן שאנחנו מוכנים לחכות לתשובה,
אם אתם מעדיפים לחשוב על זמן, אז האלגוריתם בעלות האקספוננציאלית יעבוד רק עבור קלטים
עד אורך מסוים,
בעוד שבאופן כללי, האלגוריתם
בעלות הפולינומית יאפשר לנו לפתור את
הבעיה עבור קלטים גדולים יותר.
וזו הסיבה שלמשל, אנחנו יכולים בקלות לחשב מחלקים משותפים מקסימליים למספרים עם אלפי
ביטים, אבל במקרה הגרוע,
אנחנו לא יכולים לפרק לגורמים מספרים בגודל הזה.
בחלק האחרון של השיעור, נפנה את תשומת הלב ליישום חישובים קלאסיים
על מחשבים קוונטיים.
ליתר דיוק, נראה
שכל חישוב שניתן לבצע על ידי circuit בוליאני ניתן גם לביצוע על ידי circuit קוונטי
בערך באותה עלות. יתרה מזאת, זה יכול להיעשות
בצורה נקייה שחשובה אם אנחנו
רוצים להריץ את החישובים האלה
כתת-שגרות בתוך
חישובים קוונטיים גדולים יותר, ואני אסביר למה אני מתכוון ב"נקייה" כשנגיע עמוק יותר בדיון.
אנחנו הולכים להשתמש
בשערי Toffoli בתהליך הזה.
נזכיר ששערי Toffoli הם שערי controlled-controlled-NOT, אז הפעולה שלהם על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים
היא כפי שאתם רואים כאן על המסך.
שימו לב שאפשר גם
לחשוב על שערי Toffoli כעל שערי query
עבור פונקציית AND.
זה לא אומר שהם שערי query במובן המילולי. כפי שהזכרתי בתחילת השיעור, אנחנו לא עובדים בתוך מודל
ה-query בשלב הזה,
אלא שהפעולה שלהם עוקבת אחרי אותו דפוס כמו שער query.
אפשר לחשוב על הערכים הבינאריים A ו-B כקלט לפונקציית AND וכמו שער query,
הערכים האלה מוחזרים
כחלק מהפלט והערך של הפונקציה, כלומר ה-AND הלוגי של A ו-B
עובר XOR על ה-qubit התחתון. עכשיו, לא כללנו שערי Toffoli בסט השערים הסטנדרטי שלנו.
היינו יכולים לשנות את דעתנו אם רצינו, אבל אנחנו לא באמת צריכים
לעשות את זה כי לחלופין, אפשר ליישם שערי Toffoli
באמצעות שערי Hadamard,
שערי T ו-T דאגר
ושערי controlled NOT כפי שאתם רואים כאן.
זה בכלל לא ברור
שה-circuit הספציפי הזה מיישם שער Toffoli, אבל הוא כן, ואתם יכולים או לסמוך עליי
או לכפול הכל בעצמכם כדי לקבל קצת תרגול נוסף, או שאתם יכולים פשוט לשאול את Qiskit או Python
או כל תוכנה שמכפילה מטריצות לעשות את הכפל בשבילכם.
ואתם יכולים לבדוק את
תוכן הספר של השיעור כדי לראות את זה נעשה באמצעות Qiskit.
עכשיו אנחנו יכולים לעבור לסימולציה של שערים בוליאניים עם circuits קוונטיים וכל מה שנצטרך
לזה הם שערי NOT,
שערי controlled NOT ושערי Toffoli.
הפעולות האלה כולן דטרמיניסטיות בנוסף לכך שהן יוניטריות ולפעמים אנחנו מתארים
פעולות כאלה כהפיכות, ולמעשה,
החקירה של חישוב הפיך קדמה למחשוב קוונטי ומשם כל ההליך
הזה בעצם מגיע.
השערים הבוליאניים שאנחנו צריכים
לדאוג לגביהם הם שערי NOT, שערי AND ושערי FANOUT,
ומה שאנחנו הולכים להראות הוא שאפשר ליישם את השערים האלה, או לסמלץ אותם אם אתם
מעדיפים, באמצעות שערי NOT,
שערי controlled NOT ושערי Toffoli.
ליתר בהירות, מה שאנחנו
רוצים הם circuits קוונטיים שמאפשרים לנו לחשב את הערכים של השערים הבוליאניים שהזכרתי
כשאנחנו נותנים להם qubits
במצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים כקלט.
עבור קלטים במצב קוונטי שרירותי, הפעולה תיקבע
על ידי ליניאריות כרגיל.
אנחנו לא צריכים לעשות שום דבר
מיוחד עם שערי NOT. שערי NOT הם שערי NOT ואפשר ליישם אותם ישירות.
ושערי OR ניתנים לסימולציה
באמצעות שערי Toffoli ושערי NOT.
שערי AND הם קלים, במיוחד לאור מה שאמרתי לפני כמה רגעים על שערי Toffoli שהם בעצם
יישומי שערי query
של פונקציית AND.
ליתר דיוק, מה שאפשר לעשות הוא להכניס qubit חדש שמאותחל למצב אפס
ולתת ל-qubit הזה להיות
המטרה של שער ה-Toffoli שלנו ולתת לשני
ה-qubits של הקלט להיות הבקרים.
שמות שונים ניתנים
ל-qubits נוספים כאלה, שלעתים קרובות מוכנסים
לחישובים קוונטיים ואני אקרא להם qubits
של מרחב עבודה סתם כדי לבחור שם.
ההנחה הרגילה שלנו לגבי qubits של מרחב עבודה היא שהם מתחילים במצב אפס ואנחנו לעתים קרובות יכולים להחזיר
אותם למצב אפס
כשסיימנו איתם, אבל לא תמיד.
בתרשים יש לנו ket אפס בתוך המלבן המקווקו כדי לציין שהאתחול של ה-qubit הזה
הוא חלק מהתהליך, ואם אין לכם
qubit טרי כזה, אתם לא הולכים להיות מסוגלים
לעשות את הסימולציה הזו.
ה-qubit התחתון בפלט
הוא זה שאכפת לנו ממנו כי זו התוצאה
של פעולת ה-AND ואנחנו בעצם
סיימנו עם השניים האחרים
אז הם יכולים להישאר בתוך הקופסה.
למעשה, אפשר אפילו לדמיין שהיפטרות משני ה-qubits האלה היא חלק מהעבודה של
סימולציה של שער AND הזה,
קצת כמו זבל שצריך
לנקות אותו.
אבל בכל מקרה, ככה אנחנו
יכולים לסמלץ שער AND.
עכשיו שאנחנו יודעים איך לעשות שערי AND, אנחנו יכולים לעשות שערי OR באמצעות
אחד מחוקי De Morgan.
אם שמים שערי NOT על שני הקלטים ועל הפלט של שער
AND, מקבלים שער OR, אז זה פשוט ככה.
והאחרון הוא FANOUT, ובשביל זה, כל מה
שצריך הוא שער controlled NOT ביחד עם qubit של מרחב עבודה.
ספציפית, אם אנחנו
קובעים את ה-qubit של מרחב העבודה כמטרה, אנחנו למעשה פשוט מעתיקים כל מצב בסיס סטנדרטי שנכנס,
אז זה פועל כמו שער FANOUT.
אז יש לנו את כל השערים שלנו.
ועכשיו שיש לנו את כל השערים, אנחנו יכולים לעבור ל-circuits.
בואו נניח שיש לנו
איזה circuit בוליאני בשם C, וזה יכול להיות כל
circuit בוליאני שתבחרו
כל עוד הוא מורכב מ
שערי AND או NOT ו-FANOUT.
נסמן ב-T את מספר השערים ב-C ונקרא בשם F לכל פונקציה שהיא ש-C מחשב.
אז אפשר לחשוב על F כבעלת הצורה שאתם רואים כאן, כאשר N הוא מספר ביטי הקלט של C,
M הוא מספר ביטי הפלט וסיגמא היא האלפבית הבינארי.
ומה שאנחנו עושים הוא פשוט לעבור אחד אחד דרך השערים של C.
אנחנו משאירים את שערי ה-NOT כמו שהם ומחליפים את האחרים בסימולציות
שתיארתי הרגע.
אז אם C נראה ככה, אז מה שמקבלים הוא circuit
R שנראה ככה.
בתרשים הזה, כל
qubits מרחב העבודה שאנחנו צריכים לסימולציות הוצאו מהקופסאות שלהם ונאספו בתחתית.
אז K הוא המספר הכולל של
qubits מרחב עבודה שאנחנו צריכים, שזה אחד לכל אחד מהשערים של C מלבד שערי ה-NOT.
עבור הפלט של R, יש לנו את ה-qubits
שמתאימים לפלט של C, וכאן ה-qubits
האלה מוצגים למעלה,
למרות שזה לא באמת משנה בסוף כל זה
אם הם למעלה או לא.
ליתר דיוק, בהנחה שהרצנו את R על מצב בסיס סטנדרטי שמתאים ל
מחרוזת שרירותית באורך N בשם X,
M ה-qubits של הפלט יהיו במצב בסיס סטנדרטי
שמתאים ל-F של X.
יש לנו גם את כל ה-qubits שנשארו משערי ה-AND ושערי ה-OR.
אנחנו עדיין צריכים להתחשב בהם, ואם נאסוף את כולם ביחד, הם יהיו באיזשהו מצב בסיס סטנדרטי.
מה שמצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי הזה הוא חייב להיות איזו פונקציה של המחרוזת X, ואנחנו הולכים לתת
לפונקציה הזו את השם G.
אז G היא פונקציה חדשה שנקבעת
על ידי השערים של C שאומרת לנו באיזה מצב
ה-qubits שנותרו נמצאים
אחרי שמריצים את R. G היא האות הבאה אחרי F, אז זו סיבה אחת לקרוא
לפונקציה הזו G,
אבל סיבה נוספת לקרוא לה G היא כי G זה קיצור של garbage.
כל אלה הם qubits זבל, ובפרט, יש
לנו שני qubits זבל לכל שער AND ולכל שער OR.
המספר הכולל של שערים
שאנחנו צריכים הוא big-O של T.
זה בגלל שלכל שער של C, אנחנו צריכים מספר חסום של שערים קוונטיים.
שער ה-OR הוא היקר ביותר. בשבילו, צריך שלושה שערי NOT ביחד עם שער Toffoli אחד,
ושער Toffoli עולה לנו 15 שערים מסט השערים הסטנדרטי.
אז זה לכל היותר 18 שערים
ב-R לכל שער של C.
אם רציתם לייעל את זה, הייתם יכולים, אבל למטרות ניתוח
אסימפטוטי גס, אפשר פשוט להגיד ש
ל-R יש big-O של T שערים.
אז הצלחנו לחשב
את אותה פונקציה F שה-circuit הבוליאני
המקורי C חישב,
ועשינו את זה בעלות שהיא ליניארית בגודל של C.
אם כל מה שאכפת לנו הוא
לחשב את הפונקציה F הזו, אז סיימנו.
אבל לצערנו, יש
לנו את ה-qubits הזבל האלה וה-qubits הזבל האלה
בדרך כלל הולכים להרוס
את דפוסי ההתאבכות שגורמים לאלגוריתמים קוונטיים לעבוד אם ננסה להשתמש ב-circuit
R הזה כתת-שגרה
בתוך אלגוריתם קוונטי גדול יותר.
אבל אנחנו למעשה יכולים
להיפטר מהזבל הזה, והדרך שבה אפשר לעשות
את זה היא לנצל את העובדה שה-circuit R ניתן להיפוך,
או במילים אחרות, אנחנו
יכולים להריץ אותו הפוך.
כדי להמחיש איך זה עובד, בואו נדמיין שקודם מריצים את R ואז מריצים את R הפוך,
שאפשר לבטא כ-R דאגר.
ליתר בהירות, המשמעות היא שמפעילים את השערים
של R בסדר הפוך ולוקחים את ההופכיים
של כל אחד מהשערים.
שערי NOT, שערי controlled NOT
ושערי Toffoli הם בעצם ההופכיים של עצמם, אז אם אנחנו חושבים במונחים
של השערים האלה,
אז R דאגר הוא פשוט R עם השערים מסופקים
בסדר הפוך.
אבל באופן כללי, תמיד אפשר להריץ כל circuit קוונטי יוניטרי הפוך באופן שתיארתי הרגע,
כלומר שמפעילים את
השערים בסדר ההפוך ומחליפים כל אחד
מהשערים הבודדים בהופכי שלו.
אם היינו עושים את זה, היינו מגלים שקודם להריץ את R ואז להריץ את R
הפוך לא עושה כלום בכלל.
אז אם התחלנו במצב בסיס סטנדרטי כמו שיש לנו כאן, אז היינו מסיימים בדיוק באותו מצב בסיס סטנדרטי.
כמובן, לעשות רק
את זה לא מאוד מועיל, אבל מה שאפשר לעשות הוא להכניס כמה qubits נוספים וספציפית,
מדובר ב-M qubits כאשר M הוא מספר ביטי הפלט של ה-circuit C.
ה-qubits הנוספים האלה יכולים
להיות בכל מצב קוונטי, אבל כדי להסביר איך זה עובד, נניח שהם במצב בסיס סטנדרטי
שמתאים לאיזו מחרוזת Y. אז Y היא מחרוזת באורך M ביטים, ומה שאפשר לעשות הוא לבצע
כמה שערי controlled NOT
כפי שאתם רואים כאן, שלמעשה עושים XOR של המחרוזת F של X
על המחרוזת Y שמאוחסנת
ב-M ה-qubits התחתונים.
ואז הפלט של
כל החישוב הוא כפי שמופיע על המסך.
X ו-Y הם מחרוזות בינאריות שרירותיות. ל-X יש N ביטים ול-Y יש M ביטים, ואנחנו גם צריכים K qubits של מרחב עבודה.
כשמריצים את R, מחשבים את F של X והמחרוזת הזו נשמרת
ב-M ה-qubits העליונים, אבל יש לנו גם
כמה qubits זבל,
אז עושים XOR של הפלט F של
X על M ה-qubits התחתונים ואז מריצים את R הפוך
כדי לנקות את הזבל.
חשוב לציין שזה חשוב ש-R הוא דטרמיניסטי.
אם M ה-qubits העליונים האלה היו יכולים להיות במקום זאת באיזו סופרפוזיציה של
מצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים, זה לא היה עובד נכון,
אבל זה כן עובד כש-R
הוא דטרמיניסטי.
אז אם נשווה את ה-circuit
הקוונטי שזה עתה בנינו ל-circuit הבוליאני המקורי C, נראה שהוא בעצם
עובד באותה דרך
ששער query עובד
עבור פונקציה שרירותית.
יש כאן הבדל, שהוא שאנחנו צריכים
את ה-qubits של מרחב העבודה האלה כדי שהכל יעבוד, אבל מלבד זאת למעשה בנינו שער query
או circuit של query לכל פונקציה שהיא ש-C מחשב.
גם הצלחנו, אגב, להחזיר את qubits
מרחב העבודה למצב ההתחלתי שלהם, אז הם עקרונית יכולים לשמש שוב
כ-qubits מרחב עבודה
לחישובים הבאים.
אם רוצים, אפשר לשים קופסה מסביב לכל ה-circuit הקוונטי ולקרוא לו Q והקשר ל-C
נהיה יותר ברור.
ה-circuit Q יהיה
גדול יותר מ-C באופן כללי. אנחנו צריכים קומץ שערים קוונטיים
ב-Q לכל שער של C,
ואנחנו גם צריכים את שערי
ה-controlled NOT באמצע, אבל המספר עדיין
ליניארי בגודל של C.
צריך גם לציין שזה הליך כללי לחלוטין שעובד לכל circuit בוליאני, ובכלל לא ניסינו לייעל את Q.
עבור circuit ספציפי C, יתכן מאוד שיש
דרכים לצמצם את הגודל של Q, וזה כולל שימוש בשיטות
שמפחיתות את מספר
qubits מרחב העבודה הנדרשים למקרה שזה משהו
שאנחנו רוצים לעשות, וזה ההליך להרצת
חישובים קלאסיים
על מחשב קוונטי.
זה די פשוט, אבל זה דבר חשוב
שצריך להיות מסוגלים לעשות.
בפרט, עכשיו שאנחנו
יודעים איך לעשות את זה, אנחנו חופשיים להשתמש בכל חישוב קלאסי שנרצה
בתוך חישובים קוונטיים, בתנאי שנעקוב אחרי הצורה הזו שבה הקלט מוחזר והפלט עובר XOR
על כמה qubits
בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו עבור שערי query.
העלות גדלה באופן ליניארי. אז למשל, אפשר
ליצור circuits קוונטיים לבעיות כמו חיבור מספרים שלמים,
כפל, חילוק, חישוב מחלקים משותפים מקסימליים והעלאה בחזקה מודולרית, וכל זה יכול להיעשות באותה עלות אסימפטוטית
כמו עבור circuits בוליאניים.
אנחנו כן צריכים qubits של מרחב עבודה לשם כך, אבל לפחות הם זמינים לשימוש חוזר כש
סיימנו איתם.
הערה אחרונה ששווה להזכיר היא שהשיטה הזו מספקת לנו דרך ליישם שערי query,
שרמזתי עליהם בשיעור הקודם.
כלומר, אם יש לנו אלגוריתם query שלוקח איזו פונקציה F כקלט, ויש לנו דרך לחשב
את F עם circuit בוליאני,
אז אפשר לעקוב אחרי ההליך הזה כדי לבנות שער query לפונקציה הזו ואז להריץ את אלגוריתם ה-query שלנו עליו.
אם זה דבר שימושי לעשות או לא תלוי בבעיית ה-query עצמה ומה שאנחנו מנסים להשיג, אבל בעיקרון, הבנייה
הזו מספקת לנו
דרך לחבר את מודל ה-query למודל חישוב סטנדרטי יותר.
במובן מסוים ככה אלגוריתם Shor לפירוק מספרים שלמים לגורמים עובד.
אנחנו הולכים לבנות
circuits קוונטיים כאלה מכמה מהפעולות האריתמטיות שדיברנו עליהן קודם בשיעור.
ועל ידי כך, אנחנו
נותנים ל-circuits קוונטיים את היכולת להעריך את הפעולות האלה על סופרפוזיציות של מצבים קלאסיים.
וכפי שנראה, זה מאפשר לנו לפרק מספרים שלמים לגורמים ביעילות.
זה סוף השיעור הזה, שהתמקד בעיקר בביסוס יסודות
לאלגוריתמים קוונטיים במסגרת חישובית סטנדרטית שאינה
קופסה שחורה.
דיברנו על עלות חישובית בעיקר דרך הפריזמה של בעיות הקשורות לתורת מספרים בסיסית.
דנו בעלות פולינומית
לעומת עלות אקספוננציאלית עבור משימות חישוביות, וראינו איך חישובים קלאסיים
ניתנים ליישום על ידי circuits קוונטיים בצורה נקייה ללא זבל שמאפשרת להשתמש בהם כתת-שגרות
בתוך חישובים קוונטיים גדולים יותר.
אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי לשיעור הבא שבו נראה איך האלגוריתם של Shor מנצל את הרעיונות האלה, ומאפשר לנו לפרק
מספרים שלמים לגורמים בעלות פולינומית.
להתראות עד אז.